RYAN MATSUMOTO: Cloud Bigtable
is Google Cloud's NoSQL
database that's
optimized for use cases
with high numbers
of reads and writes
per second at low latency.
In previous episodes, we learned
about Bigtable speed, scale,
and reliability,
as well as how it's
being used for use cases like
personalization and fraud
detection.
In this episode, we're
going to learn more about
how Bigtable can be used
in the ad tech industry.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Have you ever browsed one
of your favorite websites
and seen an advertisement
that just happens
to align with your interests?
The advertising technology,
or ad tech industry,
is all about the systems,
software, and tools
that advertisers use
to deliver digital ads
to potential customers.
The goal of ad tech is to help
both publishers and advertisers
optimize their
online ad campaigns.
Publishers, which could
include popular websites
and mobile apps, want to
monetize their digital space
by serving ads to their users.
Advertisers on the
other hand, want
to optimize the
ROI of ad campaigns
for their products by
efficiently reaching
target customers.
One of the most
popular ad tech models
is the open exchange, where
automated real-time bidding
options are used to decide which
ad appears in front of a user
as they load a page.
Another important part of ad
tech is using the power of data
to help digital advertisers
reach the right audiences.
Some examples of data
that might be helpful
include demographics, referring
sites, search queries,
behavior on the site, and
interaction with ad content.
When you go on a
publisher app or website,
the publisher might
send information
to an ad exchange
that will look you up
by identification or by
cohort and characteristics.
Different ad tech
companies might
offer different solutions,
but the pattern of looking up
the user is similar.
Sounds like a good case
for a key value store, no?
Bigtable is a great database
solution for ad tech companies
because of several key business
critical challenges they face.
First, ad tech companies
need to make sure
that they can serve
ads as fast as possible
when a user opens a page.
Delivering ads faster translates
to a better user experience,
making potential customers
more likely to click on ads
and improve ROI for advertisers.
In practice, this means
that many ad tech companies
need database requests
to have latency
on the order of single
digit milliseconds.
Bigtable is a great
option for this use case
since it's designed to
support large numbers of reads
and writes per second
at low latency.
Ad tech companies also need
a database that can scale.
They might have billions of ad
requests per day and millions
of requests per second.
This kind of extremely
high throughput
might overwhelm many on-premise
or traditional databases.
Luckily, Bigtable is designed
for this exact use case.
It supports up to
millions of read
and write requests per
second and can store up
to petabytes of data.
Throughput can be
adjusted dynamically
by adding or removing
Bigtable nodes,
each of which
provides up to 10,000
additional queries per second
as well as additional storage
capacity.
Ad tech companies also want to
focus on their core technology
like the machine
learning algorithms
used to optimize ad
placement, rather than worry
about how to manage
their underlying database
infrastructure.
As a fully managed
database service,
Bigtable makes it easy
for development teams
to focus on innovation rather
than reinventing the wheel.
Bigtable replicates data
across multiple Google data
centers all around the world
to maintain high availability
and low latency for
users everywhere.
This makes it easy
for ad tech companies
to seamlessly expand
to new markets
without having to
worry about managing
the data centers themselves.
Bigtable also handles backups.
So ad tech companies
can easily recover
from application-level
data corruption, as well as
human error.
Ad tech companies also
find Bigtable useful
because of how easy it is to
integrate with other Google
Cloud products.
Some companies have used
Memorystore from Memcached
to cache frequently
queried data.
This can help get latency down
to lower than one millisecond,
and also help optimize
Bigtable costs.
Other companies have
also extensively used
BigQuery, Google Cloud's
large scale data warehouse
for storage and analysis.
While Bigtable can handle very
high throughput at low latency,
BigQuery can be better for
large scale data analysis.
In the ad tech
space, BigQuery can
be helpful for
data scientists who
may want to compile analytics
and dashboards to help
advertisers and publishers
meet their goals.
Powerful and
complex queries that
may take several minutes to
complete with other databases
may take just seconds
with BigQuery.
And finally, ad tech
companies rely heavily
on machine learning to take
the data that's available
and use it to better
connect advertisers
and potential customers.
Vertex AI is Google
Cloud's unified machine
learning platform.
It makes it easy for businesses
to build, deploy, and scale
ML models on Google's
infrastructure.
As you can see, Bigtable's
speed, scalability,
and reliability make it a great
fit for the unique challenges
of ad tech.
If you're curious to learn more,
take a look at the links below.
Thanks for joining us
today, and take a look
at the other episodes
in the series
to learn more about Bigtable.